Speaker 1: Well. Welcome, everybody. Today is
a Friday show, sort of. I know it's Wednesday,
but it's our last show for the week because of
the upcoming Thanksgiving holiday and sort of a
Friday show in format will be taking a few
live calls later, but not quite as many as
we normally would on Friday. I do have a bunch
of stories I want to talk about and I want to
start with what we all knew was only going to be
a matter of time. Right wing media is now blaming
the victims of the club. Q Shooting in Colorado.
You know, I didn't cover this shooting already,
and I got a couple of e-mails asking why. I'm
going to delve into it more next week, actually.
But when these shootings happen, first of all, I
will often wait a couple of days because I want
to get the information right. And these shootings
are so common. I mean, just look at gun violence,
archive.org oftentimes. There's not that much more
to say. Now, this one had a particularly nefarious
element to it in that it does appear that the
target was chosen because of anti LGBT sentiment
and because of now the use of the term groomer
by the right, which is basically applied as a
typically sexually predatory or otherwise
predatory term to everything from drag
shows to just a gay couple that wants to adopt a
kid. They are now using that framing to do some
victim blaming. And I'm going to play a couple of
examples for you. Here is one from Tucker Carlson,
where his guest, Jamie Mitchell, who is the
founder of an organization called Gays Against
Groomers, helps Tucker Carlson say, listen,
this is going to continue until we end gender
affirming care. Listen to these disgusting people.
Speaker 2: Right. I mean, it shouldn't have to be
said, but what is anti LGBTQ that these people
need to understand? And what is putting our
community in great danger is claiming that all
of us support this and just associating all of
us with this, you know, saying that groomer is an
anti LGBTQ slur that is doing irreparable damage
to us as a whole and is putting a really large
target on our backs. And unfortunately, you know,
the tragedy that happened in Colorado Springs
the other night, you know, it was expected and
predictable. We all, within gays against groomers
saw this coming from a mile away. And sadly,
I don't think it's going to stop until we end
this evil agenda that is attacking children.
Speaker 1: Now by evil agenda. She's referring to
gender affirming care, which we've already talked
about in detail. It is not some wild, heretical
thing. It is actually something based in years
and years now of study, and they want to frame
it as basically perverts doing things to your
kids. So so saying, listen, this is going to keep
happening until we stop gender affirming care.
They're not even hiding it at this point. There's
no consequences for them, at least not thus far.
So why would they stop? They wouldn't. Here is
another example. This is Matt Walsh. Matt Walsh,
we've talked about him before. He's become very
known among right wing cultural circles, in social
circles, as the guy who really hammers on this.
Speaker 3: Scourge.
Speaker 1: Of transgender, gender affirming
care, etc.. Here he is doing another version
of Look What You Made Me Do to You.
That's a classic from abusers. Why do
you keep making me punch you in the face?
Speaker 3: Family friendly drag shows,
quote unquote. Have to purposes one from the drag
queens perspective is to satisfy their fetish for
cross-dressing in front of children. The other on
a more macro level, is to indoctrinate children
into queer theory. To put it simply, the point
of drag queen story hour. And the child the
supposed family friendly drag shows is to
turn your children queer. That is the goal.
And whenever you see that.
Speaker 1: By the way, consider
how insane that is. Consider how absurd that is
given the reality of what we know about sexual
orientation. Turn your children queer. This is
it's it's seem this guy was in diapers when that
talking point was already being debunked.
Speaker 3: You said right there as we clip
by Media Matters. Hello, everybody on Twitter,
the people who invented it stated explicitly that
that is the point to help children live. Clearly,
that's their quote. And the thing about the
left is that what they believe and what they do,
all of it is so horrifying, so perverse,
so degraded that if you just quote them.
Then you somehow sound like the crazy one. If you
quote what they are saying and they said it sounds
crazy just to say it out loud because it's so
horrifying. Yet. It's true. And this is the reason
the left care so much about this, and they defend
it so vigorously because according to the left,
think about this. According to the left,
the drag queen child combination has become
dangerous. They say it's a lightning rod for
violent backlash. Right. That's what they say.
And it's greatly exaggerated, of course. Mostly
it's invented out of whole cloth, actually, but.
But even by their version of events, if it's
causing this much chaos and violence, why do you
insist on continuing to do it right? If, according
to you, it's like putting people's lives at risk?
If the effort to have men cross-dressing for
children is putting people's lives at risk, why
are you still doing it? Is it that important to
you? Now, as always, they try to flip the burden
around on us. They demand that we explain why we
object to children being exposed to drag queens.
Speaker 1: But of course, it's not about
objection, it's about violence. And this is,
of course, outrageous, right. Listen, if the thing
you're doing is angering lunatics so much that
they shoot at you, just stop doing the thing.
Isn't that exactly the type of speech they say
shouldn't be curtailed by threats of violence?
It doesn't make any sense. And these folks,
this one from day one, had a tinge to it where
we knew they were going to blame the victims.
If you just stop doing this crazy stuff, then
people wouldn't go and start shooting you up.
Blame the victims. Blame. They often do
it with rape and they're doing it here.